hi guys how's it going so today we're
gonna be doing some fun touristy things
I'm not even sure if you can hear me
hold on his neck so who you were just
filming in Barcade it's like a super
cool arcade and we're doing a fun little
shoot I don't know what we're gonna do
I never know what we're doing but that's
the joy of every day I just changed and
now we're gonna go do some touristy fun
things so first we're gonna be going to
drag brunch I didn't know that's the
thing but it's a thing
you guys getting the shot look at that
see your accent it's a crappy video I
think I do
okay let's do this
it's had a dog in a bag and it was so
cute it looked like life of jinki if you
guys follow him on Instagram I think
actually Jinky my girl but what if that
was jinke
oh my goodness that was quite the
experience I don't think I could even
put half of the things in that she said
to me but I'm gonna try it my bat it's
not pg-13 now we're gonna go get a
milkshake these are so crazy we were
going to this place that has these crazy
milkshake we saw them on Instagram is
that milkshake veil to have a line
it's really driving here so we're
preparing the Lighting's to get photos
of the milkshake
I just had the best milkshakes of my
life thank you blacked out so right now
we're going to the Samsung store it's
really it really cool so I'm kind of
excited to check it out it's not a great
day or doing very random things in New
York
Samsung sorry here we go my flip screen
out so I didn't know Oh creeping no way
yes I knew it
that's amazing Matt hello how are you
yes that's awesome I knew you look at
Justine oh do you think I can't believe
in buying a winter coat in May either
why did I bring a jacket here this is
insanity I just keep it on my body while
I check out I've been seeing all of
these people carry these things around
and I didn't know what it was
I'm Spencer I know I just watched your
video
come get free art do we get the free art
should we get the free art let's let's
get the art
this is where Maddie needs to do his
album release party DJ over here in that
DJ booth everybody go this is perfect
this is so cool most films
should we watch one of my youtube videos
we just watch all of Maddie's cute puppy
video now what do we do I don't know try
some phones your VR yeah this is like
Drake video play hotline bling here we
got this
you want to check out
cool so I'm basically putting my
Instagram name in here it's an art
installation so what is it excusing all
the phones or I'm not telling you
anything I have to tell them well then
you're in for surprise we're in far as
the private that would you should scape
your reaction take your time this is
gonna be wild
wild
darn
now we're gonna go up to the High Line
to get a picture of the sunset he just
gave me a hug I'm gonna go look at the
Sun